when Governor Ronda Sanz abruptly
canceled his media appearances over the
weekend it led to a lot of speculation
that he'd be ending his presidential
campaign and sure enough on Sunday
that's exactly what happened facing the
prospect of a distant third place finish
in the New Hampshire primary DeSantis
bowed out and endorsed Donald Trump now
on one hand the disappointment from
desantis's supporters of which I I was
one and M1 is understandable he's a
fantastic governor who's more effective
at advancing conservative policies than
any other politician alive today there's
just no doubting that the track record
is clear at the same time there's also
no question that it's a good thing that
the primary effectively ended this
weekend as opposed to an even more
protracted war of infighting among
conservatives that leads always to the
inevitable conclusion anyway uh with
Millions more dollars wasted on
pointless attack ads and everything else
we're not going to do that Donald Trump
will be the party's nominee and that's
going to be the case no matter how often
Nikki Haley who's still in the race
reminds us that she's a woman of color
and and that she's and also a person of
color and a woman and she was bullied
for being Brown on the Mean Streets of
Orangeburg South Carolina but more on
that later uh this thing is over and
that means that the right can unite
against its real enemies and the real
enemies are the powerful forces in our
society who hate this country who
despise its people and who seek to
destroy our families and corrupt our
children and one of the clear examples
of this effort is the sheer scale and
dishonesty of the left's fraudulent war
against what they call book bands as
City Journal has noted politicians at
every level of government from Governor
Chris tunu in New Hampshire to former
representative L Cheney and Wyoming uh
they they all have claimed that schools
are are censoring classic reading
materials particularly in school
libraries at the behest of the
Republican Party Joe Biden has even
appointed a book band coordinator to
pursue civil rights cases against
against libraries that offend the lgbtq
cult with their censorship their alleged
censorship Biden also launched in his uh
launched his re-election bid eight
months ago with a video video falsely
implying that Florida had banned the
book To Kill a Mocking Bird which simply
was not true of course it wasn't true as
even the Associated Press later had to
admit the truth is that this campaign
against book bands is nothing more than
a crusade to put pornography in
schools um that's been clear for a while
now we've all seen the footage of
parents repeatedly getting thrown out of
school board meetings just for reading
passages from the pornographic books in
their children's School libraries so
these are books that are in the school
libraries that you can't even read out
loud at a school board meeting because
they're too graphic dozens of those
videos are out there at this point um
and this is about exposing children to
smut and you know everyone can clearly
see that anybody with with a brain and
who's honest can see that what's changed
is that now with the election rapidly
approaching the forces pushing this
degeneracy are emboldened they're
dropping the pretense that they're
worried about discrimination or teaching
history or whatever they are at this
point all but coming right out and
saying that they want to expose children
to pornographic materials and they're
doing it with the express support of the
largest media conglomerates on the
planet now if you doubt that I want you
to watch this remarkable footage from
MSNBC the other day this is from Joy
Reed's show and speaking of remarkable
it remains one of the great marvels of
the world that Joy Reed despite being
viscerally unpleasant to listen to or
look at and despite having nothing
important to say and having never
offered an even mildly interesting
insight into any topic ever in her
entire life still has a show that for
yet another week has not been canceled
then again this is MSNBC I mean they
they specialize in giving
extraordinarily annoying and unappealing
and stupid people TV shows Al Sharpton
still has a show on that Network after
all last I checked although I've never
really checked to be honest anyway back
to Joy Reed so she was interviewing the
co-founder founder of the group moms for
Liberty which is uh and the the group is
co-founded by a woman named Tiffany
Justice now before I show you the clip
here's the
backstory U what's bothering onbc is
that moms for Liberty does not want a
book called all boys aren't blue a
memoir Manifesto written by lgbtq
activist George Johnson to be available
for children to check out from school
libraries uh this is a book that
includes descriptions of anal rape and
incest which are too graphic for me to
read on the air and this is the
disadvantage that we find ourselves in
when it comes to this issue uh which is
that you really need to hear
specifically what's in these books to
fully appreciate just how deranged these
people are for wanting to put these
books in schools but the material is so
objectionable and disgusting and
embarrassing that I simply will not read
it out loud so you know I mean you could
look it up for yourself and see but
suffice it to say that the book contains
very very detailed accounts of rape
sodomy uh and and other things that uh
you really don't want your kids reading
about and there are
look there are hundreds of thousands of
books in circulation that do not have
any of that sort of
content okay so that there's just no
reason why this book especially of all
books needs to be in a school
library as I've tried to explain in the
past almost every book that's ever been
written will not be in any school
library or in any school at all you know
like because there's so many books so no
matter what you're you're choosing a a
very small like thimble sized portion of
all the books that have ever been
written to to be in your in your uh
school all the other books are not going
to be
there and so when you decide that oh
well this book in particular needs to be
in the
school when you got all these other
books available it really raises a lot
of questions about your motives I
shouldn't really say they're not really
questions I mean we know what your
motives are so this is a book that
according to local reports is available
in the young adult non-fiction section
of two libraries in Huntsville Alabama
these sections are for children between
the ages of 12 and 18 which is roughly
in line with the Publishers age
recommendation for this book and
according to moms for Liberty there are
records of CH a child as young as nine
checking out all boys AR Blue from the
library what's incredible is that in
this interview Joy Reed does not dispute
anything about the content of the book
or how obscene it is uh she doesn't she
doesn't concede that maybe 9-year-old
children shouldn't be reading this
instead she goes out of her way to
defend the book Joy Reed Begins by
complaining that parents are going
online and sharing passages from the
book that she says are somehow taken out
of context and then she makes a very
familiar argument from there
watch the question I'm asking is what is
the expertise that you have and other
moms for Liberty Advocates have to
decide that a book an award-winning book
like all boys aren't blue isn't
appropriate for students to read what
what a tragic story of a young man who's
annally raped by his adult family member
so you have incest rape pedophilia Joy
you said you'd let me answer so I'm
going to answer for you um in what
context is a strap on dildo acceptable
for public school just let I mean that's
my question to you tell me what the
context around a strap on dildo or the
rape of a minor Child by a
teacher we're talking about public
school one moment all right so now
you've ask me questions I'm I'm going to
answer it well who is the main character
what's the name of the main character in
all boys AR Blue you're asking me right
now you just gave me very specific
information about this book so you're
presenting yourself as somebody expert
the who's the main character in the book
The main character is the author who's
the what's his name George I believe is
his first name because you're giving me
very specific information that is ask
remember the name of an
author here's my question talking you
didn't my question I'm going to I'm
going to answer your question I would
love to hear that absolutely well I I'm
interviewing you and you're not
interviewing me so let's just make sure
it's a conversation okay so what I'm
saying to you is that as you are not an
expert in this book I don't have to
expert aren't appropiate for public
school I mean on let's get
real yeah and she never really gets
around to an answer by the way because
of course there is no way to answer that
like what's the context for anal rape or
strap on dildo as was asked that uh that
would make it acceptable for a child
what what context makes that so that
okay you freak you disgusting freak like
that we even have to ask you that
question it it's it's like I I applaud
Tiffany Justice for being able
to being able to contain her disgust to
the level that she does um I find very
impressive I would not be able to to do
that because you Joy reer just a an
awful awful
person and and there just evil like evil
to your freaking core that you want to
expose this to kids but all she has as
well she says you're not an expert
unlike unlike whoever gave this
pornographic book an award they're the
experts so therefore shut up you don't
have to you don't get to have an opinion
that's what she's saying you may have
noticed that it's become a of course a
common rhetorical tactic on the left
whether they're talking about climate
change or transgenderism or book bands
or pretty much anything in the absence
of any guiding moral principles they've
now they're now fully reliant on the
expert class to the point that they
can't think for themselves anymore about
anything and they don't want you to
think for yourself either it's just a
reflex now what do the experts say like
the experts about what we're at the
point where they don't want you to
object to pornography in the children
section without first getting an experts
approval I mean just think about that
for a moment Joy Reed is claiming that
you cannot object to children being
exposed to books about anal rape unless
you are an expert which raises the
question Joy expert in what like what
the hell kind of expert do you need to
be to understand the simple Common Sense
fact that 12-year-olds don't need to be
reading graphic sexual content I mean
how long until they tell you you're not
allowed to object to full-on child
pornography or pedophilia unless you are
an
expert based on their logic at this rate
it probably won't be long in fact that's
basically where we are right now of
course in that clip Joy uh takes this
approach to a new level of absurdity
when she demands that Tiffany Justice
named the author of the book all boys
aren't blue and I mean it's the dumbest
gotcha I've ever seen and I guess
because Justice couldn't provide the
guy's full name quickly enough we're
supposed to conclude that she's not an
expert in the book you don't need to be
an expert in
this and and and therefore she's she's
excluded from having an opinion on the
topic because you know you can't object
to children being exposed to sexual
content unless you can give the full
name of the person who created the
sexual content makes total sense if you
have brain damage and speaking of brain
damage what follows from Joy Reed next
as you probably would have guessed is
the usual disingenuous parental rights
argument the idea is that parents should
be able to expose their children to
whatever they want and reasonable people
shouldn't be allowed to step in and
prevent that and know these people don't
give a damn about parental rights in any
context except when it's parents who
want to expose their kids to sexual
content or parents who want to mutilate
and uh and uh and castrate their kids so
those are the only times that these
demons uh care about about parental
rights let's
watch why is it your right or a mom's
for Liberty activist's right to say that
a parent who wants their child to have
access to this book which gives a
personal experience of this author that
they why doesn't a liberal parent for
instance or a parent of an lgbtq kid why
don't they have a right for their child
to just have access to this book why is
it your right to say they can't so again
we're talking about incest rape and
pedophilia parent one no each parent has
to decide what is appropriate for their
child to read so I want you to answer
I'm going to ask you one more time what
is your right to tell a parent who wants
their child who might feel seen by this
story why don't they have the right why
don't they have the right as a parent to
say my child can have access to this
book if a child feels seen by this story
that means that they have been the
victim of a predator that means that
they have either been raped by a family
member they they've experienced um and
proof of that is what you just said that
a child feels seen by this story so to
recap the conversation began with joy
suggesting that the context of the book
makes it acceptable somehow but she
never explained what context would
justify showing a child a graphic
description of anal rape and incest so
now she circles back to original point
in a roundabout way she implies that
some children could benefit from reading
the story because they'd feel seen and
represented in the pages and if parents
want to encourage that then we're
supposed to go along with it now she she
actually says all that you heard
yourself and again just to be clear this
is not a book that encourages kids to
take up sports or solve Mysteries or
learn about space flight or something
this book is exposing children as young
as 9 years old to graphic scenes of anal
rape and according to the corporate
press children should read books like
this and uh and you know see themselves
in the
books as Tiffany Justice pointed out the
implications with that are pretty dark
to say the least this gets to the heart
of what this whole debate is about which
is the left's attempt to legitimize
deviant sexual contact with children I
mean it's not hard to conclude that the
reason they want to show children these
books about graphic underage sex is that
they see no problem with children
engaging in this kind of
behavior and that could be why
throughout this whole interview Joey
never once condemns the content of the
book she doesn't say that some children
probably shouldn't read it I mean she
wouldn't even concede that she wouldn't
concede anything instead she falls back
on this idea that parental rights are
absolute and we should never be able to
dictate what other parents can and can't
do even though again she doesn't give a
damn about par parental rights in any
other context but notice the incoherence
of this
argument because first Joy says that no
one can have an opinion about this book
unless they're an expert and they've
read it cover of cover and they can name
the author's full name and give his date
of birth and social security number and
a few minutes later Joyce says that
every parent should have the right to
show their kids this book and their
decision must be respected no matter
what so this is what's called a
contradiction and people who understand
basic principles of iic can spot it
right away but people like joy and the
rest of the corporate press are too
concerned with ideology to bother with
principles or logic or anything else and
that's why rather than present any kind
of argument for why children need to
read about anal sex Joy concludes the
interview by launching into bizarre
personal attacks on moms for Liberty
watch let me ask about the people who
are making the decision for their
parents because you have not answered
yet why a liberal parent or an
African-American parent we have parents
who are Democrat who are members of our
organ but you're still trying to make
decisions for all the kids here are some
of the parents that are filing uh or
some of the the the your Advocates
Bridget Ziegler the moms for Liberty
co-founder the wife of the recently
ousted Florida Republican party chairman
Christian zegler who allegely was
involved in threesum samesex threesums
um Mrs zagler was was removed from the
school board at which she was a leader
um You'
had okay you have Lauren deala um she
was making book band request in alatua
County but then records showed that she
and her husband didn't live there they'd
sold their home in that county Carrie
Blair in Tennessee who was um arrested
for property theft charges after
allegedly stealing from Target skip
scanning in Target why should those
three people get to make decisions about
what other children should be able to
read other parents' children should be
able to read now I have no idea if any
of those allegations are true um and by
the way if you really want to play this
game Joy do you want to go down the list
of all the pedophiles and sexual abusers
in the public school system okay let's
find all the teachers and administrators
that support this kind of stuff and you
want to go you want to find a list of
all the sexual abuse inflicted by those
people um so you know I don't know if if
if it's if any that's true from what
Tiffany Justice says they seem shaky but
honestly it doesn't matter this is a
painfully transparent attempt to
distract from the issue that this whole
interview was about I mean even if all
that's true even if moms for Liberty is
full the worst people on the planet okay
and that's not even like what she she
said that one of them one of them didn't
like stole from Target and didn't scan
what the hell does that have to do with
anything but even if they even if
they're like even if they're all serial
killers and Nazis and super villains
does that suddenly make it appropriate
to supply children with reading material
about anal rape like is that what you're
saying so when when a when a woman says
you know I don't think that that kid
should uh be reading books about anal
rape your response is well yeah but you
stole from
Target what does that have to do with
anything it makes no sense but this is
all Joy Reed can do she doesn't want to
talk about the books or why she wants
children to read them instead she just
wants to attack the people who are
pointing out what's in these books I
mean it's hard to put into words the
depths of the evil that is on display
here this isn't Just One race hustle or
an MSNBC talking like this is pretty
much all of the corporate press along
with the Biden
Administration all the powerful
institutions who are committed to
pushing this smut in schools it's going
to take an equally forceful concerted
effort to stop them from succeeding and
this month lawmakers in Florida
introduced a bill that represents a
really good start the legislation would
ban teachers and government employees
from displaying the so-called Pride
rainbow flag or Associated lapel pins in
public buildings and schools for obvious
reasons the flag is a symbol of a
radical religious cult that's
specifically used to Target children and
indoctrinate them into an ideology that
seeks at every turn to sexualize and
corrupt them and and soon if the bill
passes that symbol which became
omnipresent sometime in the past decade
will be gone now it's simple and
effective proposals like this that have
made Florida under Rhonda Sanz an
attractive state for conservative
families to live in he's not campaigning
for president anymore but he's still
going to be a leader in this fight which
could not be more urgent at this point
and what's needed now especially as the
primary effectively comes to a close is
for every conservative to unite unite
and join in the fight against this evil
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there